one of the arguments against the death
penalty is we need to give these guys a
time to change their mind to repent to
rehabilitate first of all hanging
concentrates the mind I sometimes think
a shorter time scale to consider
repentance is better than a longer one
but even look at the long one 32 and a
half years wasn't enough to change this
guy's mind those are the final words he
wants to go out on doesn't learn a damn
thing in prison doesn't seem to have any
remorse whatsoever
see you buddy the Civil Authority does
not wield The Sword in vain and people
need to know the public needs to know
that there are consequences to bad
actions this is basic incentives if you
don't punish bad behavior you're going
to get more bad behavior if you don't
reward good behavior then you're less
likely to get more of that good behavior
basic incentives and some of those basic
government incentives include the Noose